i ragazzi di oggi sono bimbiminkia
questa è una frase che sul web gira
molto spesso nell'ultimo periodo i
ragazzi degli anni 90 diventati adulti
adesso sono tutti quanti non rigidi da
questa generazione che si sta formando
io che sono nato negli anni novanta sono
coetaneo di quelli che si sentono
inorriditi dai ragazzi di oggi no questo
video vi mostro quoziente intellettivo
medio che avevamo noi quando avevamo la
vostra età e credetemi è decisamente
messo male alla google caverna una
parola sola che i ragazzi di oggi
sperano che tutti si siano dimenticati e
quella parola e tectonic questi eravamo
noi alla vostra età vorrei commentare
questo schifo in diretta se me lo
permettete ok benissimo due tipe che
camminano con uno slow motion che fa
veramente rizzare i capelli però va beh
dall'altra parte la gang è di 85 ragazzi
vestiti in un modo che il suo micio ti
prego non guardare questo video che
potrebbero ricrescere i capelli possiamo
vedere queste due entità avvicinarsi
l'una all'altra una sfiora la spalla del
tizio 1 le tocca il culo si gira si
girano tutti sguardi perplessi
[Musica]
secondo me degli alieni hanno
approcciato la terra nel 2007 comunque
intorno a quell anno hanno visto sta
roba si son detti torniamo indietro che
qua ancora non sono all'età della pietra
[Musica]
alla risposta del tizio che scende le
scale inizia a a svitare il proprio
braccio prima inquadratura sui culi
giustamente random l'altro ragazzo
scende incoraggiato manco fosse il rocky
balboa si svita anche lui le braccia le
altre sempre a guardarlo come se fosse
il messia va bene abbiamo capito ma
basta smontato il braccio chi sono
questi
chi cazzo sono questi sono altre persone
non c'entrano non era facciano parte
della gang ma cosa un virus si si si
attacca la gente corrono sulla scala
come se dovessero proprio contributo a
rocky balboa appena citato notare poi lo
sguardo di fatica del ragazzo che appena
salito 200 scalini approcciano quel
gruppo di ragazzi che sta facendo cose
strane e cosa faranno mai
[Musica]
non c'è non mi stupiscono loro che fanno
questo mi stupiscono gli altri che
rimangono così c'è uno viene avvicinata
in strada inizia a fare così la prima
cosa che dovresti fare è chiamare il 118
e dire ragazzi qua ci sono due pazzi
maniaci venite con la camicia di forza
che in questo caso serve un sacco invece
no
rimane così come uno zombie a guardare
sti due che balla ma continuiamo prego
che ci sono ancora perle o sono
ritornate le tipe grazie a dio me n'ero
quasi dimenticate
vai vai fratello vai vai farle vedere
chi sei e niente purtroppo il massimo
della virilità maschile questa era
questa spuntato gucci boy lui non pagava
affitto neanche dieci anni fa o
sincronizzate addirittura c'era un tizio
che ha visto la scena e per paura che lo
sa che vissero è scappato via guardate
qua destra uno che scappa aveva fatto
solo bene ha fatto bene
vabbè attenzione la tua l'atleta di
turno fermi tutti guardalo guardalo
grandissima ha fatto il salto della
scala ma questo quaeda limpidi io non è
che vi descrivereste scende cioè cosa
cazzo appena visto
[Musica]
scende un tizio con la maglia bianca non
si sa chi è e si limona la tizia macché
ma cosa ma se ai nostri tempi c'era
questa merda e tutti tutti tutti non
fatto che c'hai 22 anni come me che
magari sta volando sto video che ti
ricordi di quei tempi anche tu l'hai
fatto non mentire a se stesso so che ti
sveglia ancora la notte con gli incubi
io lo so perché lo faccio anch'io questa
era chiamata electro dance dance
generation e volete la prova che lo
facevano tutti prendiamo un creator
della mia età io sono del 95 un credo le
note mete bizet mettevi sono del 95 94
forza non hanno in più forse 93
addirittura però quel periodo nero sul
canale li mette bizet il canale mette
bizet e questo perfetto se tu a me prima
che una lentamente bizet e fari nella
barra degli indirizzi del canale di
mente bizet c'è youtube.com user matt
electro dance e quindi canali mette
business era il canale di man che si
chiamavano matt elettro dancer perché
anche mente ha dovuto fare anni di
riabilitazione per tornare essere umano
poi una riabilitazione uscita un po male
vedo però vabbè è sempre meglio di prima
sempre nel mio periodo giravano moda dei
truzzi perché ai tempi
la gente era truzza la gente [ __ ]
ovviamente è che voi ci crediate o no ai
tempi c'erano anche i tutorial su come
essere truzzi e oggi vediamo un tutorial
di susie la ragazza truzza e sono qui
per spiegarmi perché noi ragazzi
diventiamo tutti io sono così una
ragazza giusta
tentata truffa circa ieri ieri perché
proprio è una cosa tipo l'evoluzione dei
pokémon prima non lo sei e poi lo sei
subito ci vuole un giorno la magica alpa
una certa diventi gary dove un momento
in cui non sei tu sei tu solo perché
perché perché beh intanto io ascolto
musica puntus tools per bar boom studios
quella musicale apporto vestiti di marca
ovviamente per chi sennò non sarei
truzzo infatti notare dolce gabbana
porto vestiti firmati perché sennò non
sarei bruzzo infatti notare lei boy è no
perché quello sono io quello nella foto
sotto io quello ne diamo avanti truzza
perché beh io ho la collana di perle che
se non l'avessi non sei cruz ma quella
cioè la mia nonna nel portagioie alle
persone che love alle persone che cosa
le persone che la moviola alle persone
che lo fanno così male come tali
esattamente come parlano i bambini di
due anni quando hanno penalizzato a
parlare io tutto bene grazie un amo
tantissimo tanto tanto è un segno
d'affetto cioè parole d'affetto poesie
d'amore pablo neruda chi
niente niente house forever mare ma
forever si ama sempre qua questa cosa è
successo effetti speciali cpc che avete
appena visto la testimonianza di susie
una ragazza
devo subito controllare se lei
ingaggiata steven spielberg per uno dei
suoi film montaggio in diretta ma stavo
scherzando non lo faccio neanche io nei
miei video
parola di fa vj un ragazzo trendy
ragazzoni belli per me possiamo
concludere qui c'è di peggio ma tanto
peggio è che io veramente ho dato solo
un assaggino di quella che era il mio
mondo e ma questo per non ridicolizzare
troppo quella che era la mia generazione
ma ricordatevi che quando un ragazzo più
grande vita dei bimbiminkia diciamo che
non ne ha proprio tutto il diritto o
comunque ragazzo spero che vi sia
piaciuto cosa sono serviti a un momento
mi dispero che dice ai video che avete
visto spero che non vi siano piaciuti
spero vi sia piaciuto il mio come se mi
prometto che piace anche vari social
come nella descrizione ricordatevi
essere fighi essere belli non contro una
sega basta che sai svitati le braccia in
pubblico e rimorchi che un piacere da
ragazzi ecco se tu ciao
[Musica]